the ancestral lands of the caripuna
indigenous people are beautiful
but residents here live with a constant
sense of unease
they tell me it's like people keep
invading your home and breaking things
in 2021 their land was one of the eight
indigenous territories in brazil that
saw especially high levels of illegal
deforestation
[Music]
the brazilian state of hondona located
in the southern amazon its capital is
puerto vallo a faceless concrete city
adriano caripuna is constantly on god he
says most of his neighbors are
suspicious of him because he's fighting
for the course of the indigenous people
he moved here from his village seven
years ago
now at the age of 37 he's studying law
all in a bit to save his people and his
homeland
a lot of people in the city think we're
out of place here
they think we should stay in our
villages
but i'm no less indigenous just because
i live in the city
they show the same jesus or because i'm
studying
together we head out to the land of the
caripuna
the journey by car and boat takes nearly
five hours
it's been many weeks since adriano has
been home
he suddenly receives a message and
immediately contacts his lawyer
a man appears to have died on karipuna
territory and the police are
investigating
he was not a member of the community and
no one knew him it's possible he was
involved in logging
like many who enter the area illegally
adriano caribouna gathers all the
information he can as it could support
his people's ongoing lawsuit against the
state of hondona and the brazilian
government
one of those observing the growing
conflict is angelis dibrito today he's
an independent environmental advisor for
members of parliament but he previously
spent several years heading up the local
environmental authority
a real disaster has been happening in
brazil's environmental policy it's like
a demolition and an orchestrated one at
that
it's happening at local state and
federal levels and with the involvement
of the executive and legislative powers
just to give you an idea
rondonia's state parliament held a
simple vote in the middle of the night
incidentally voting to massively reduce
two protected areas that are
strategically important
the jazzy
it was just because the two areas were
reportedly stopping the expansion of
grazing land for cattle
the state's highest court ruled that the
decision contravened the constitution
but the forest is still being cleared
both areas border on karapuna land
this is where our territory begins
on the right hand side of the river
will be in the village in two and a half
hours
we pass a number of giant samama trees
they are known here as the queen of the
forest
the territory of the caribuna covers
more than 150 000 hectares
a handful of families and a host of dogs
await our arrival
the caripuna go hunting conserving the
meat with salt and leaving it to dry in
the sun
the jasi parana river is a lifeline for
the community
at the end of the rainy season the
swollen river offers welcome respite
from the heat
relative humidity is nearly 90 percent
all the children attend a single
elementary school class if they want
more schooling they have to move to the
city
right now it's time for the maniac
harvest and everyone is involved
the tubers are first soaked in water for
four days and then pressed to eliminate
the toxins
manioc has a sweet sour smell
each family has its own plot of land and
customers in the city
mania flower is an important source of
income everyone here is short of money
the process of producing the flour takes
many hours
roasting it in the heat is an art in
itself
most brazilians don't care about the
indigenous people's fight to survive
so often i hear this incorrect argument
that indigenous people own too much land
and what do they need all this land for
and i always say has anyone thought
about why some major landowner has to
have so much land
no one gives it a second thought
nearly 14 of brazil's land mass is
reserved for indigenous peoples their
right to the land is anchored in the
constitution
the karapuna population was almost wiped
out during the 1970s due to conflicts
over land and due to disease
adriano's mother was one of the few to
survive
today
is the matriarchal figure of the
community
its cultural and spiritual anchor
adriano says she gives him strength and
courage to carry on the struggle
what does she think of the repeated
invasions of the land
translates her words from karipuna for
us
they defended their land with all means
available now things are different there
are laws which the karapuna abide by
she wishes she could say the same for
the invaders
the next morning adriano's brother
andrea offers to show us where the
illegal loggers have been at work
everyone's a little bit apprehensive
they never know what they might
encounter
after well over an hour we reach an
opening
at first it doesn't look that bad
but in the forest we find swathes of
devastation
during the dry season the tree trunks
are dragged over to the other side of
the river
the illegal logging began here just over
six months ago
they estimate that around 2 000 trees
have been felt so far and the trunks
dragged away
the woods such as ipa or garapeda
fetches a high price but many of these
species are considered at risk
we are really concerned about the extent
of the logging it's so sad to come to a
place like this and see this destruction
are you afraid to come here i ask
these days we're all afraid just to move
around on our own territory
[Music]
then they discover something else new
wonderful
chainsaw chains have been left lying
around
explains that the loggers replace them
as they wear down
so it's clear they're now cutting up
some of the trunks here
the caribouna suspect that the logger's
next step will be to cover plots of land
how can land that legally belongs to the
caripuna simply be claimed by others
well first the newcomers register the
plot of land online
then while the applications are being
checked they create facts on the ground
more than 80 such applications have been
submitted for this area
it's as though it were completely normal
to destroy the forest to make way for
grazing land or soy plantations
and so it just continues and no one is
called to account
no one seeks to prosecute these crimes
against our national heritage
and for us
that's what this is
but not for these people
they just see the forest as a commodity
we want the forest to stay
they report all the violations chiefly
to the funai the government authority
that is supposed to safeguard the rights
of brazil's indigenous population
no one at funai is willing to talk to us
the karipuna say the authority turns a
blind eye to what's happening in the
amazon
andrea caripuna takes us to another part
of the forest
we send up a drone to film the area
in the capital portugal we have an
appointment at the federal prosecutor's
office whose job it is to uphold the
constitution
the public prosecutor often acts as a
regulator for issues affecting the
environment and human rights
we ask her what tools she has at her
disposal to stop this destruction
nothing that's quick she says
lengthy civil cases that drag on for
years and otherwise
respect
we always try to keep pace with these
crimes and to expose the criminal
structures behind them
and to prosecute them
but there are no state measures that are
preventive
we've had some
successes like with two of our
operations in 2019 and 2020
where we were able to curb illegal
activities on indigenous territory
flights over the area later showed that
the deforestation was reduced
but new cases keep cropping up
as long as there are no public
structures that tackle the problem at
the route all we can do is react
adriana is also in the city and has
arranged to meet a close ally
without laura vicuna from the missionary
council for indigenous peoples they
might already have lost their fight the
council has helped to document all the
illegal encroachments of recent years
with gps and it's supporting the
caripuna's lawsuit
with this legal action against the
brazilian government against the funai
authority and against the state of
rondonia the karipuna people are making
it clear that there has been enough
impunity violence and violation of
rights
the message to the judiciary is it's
time for you to wake up and take action
the caripuna are pinning their hopes on
this lawsuit which may have to go
through multiple cults for them
everything is at stake
this is where i come from
i am part of the forest
and all of this here
[Music]
you